let's think that's true if we ask
corporate for that then they are either
gonna say yes or no could go either way
we don't know what they are going to say
think we have to think it through
because if they say no can we not know
yes we have to you know why cuz I don't
like to be cooped up in that office in
that box all day long husband because I
need to think okay Jim Oh Kevin oh nice
catch mm-hmm intercept dad right here
look give it to me
don't spin me the ball okay give me the
ball Jim you guys create give me the
ball
right now give it to Brian you all right
Ryan right yeah Pam Fire Marshal Boone
we meet again detective Peralta your
fly's down it made you look I didn't
look and I'm wearing shorts there is no
fly that's not what your mom said you
make no sense and now I'm inside your
head
prepare to die
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't have to dance every time true
but I choose the day every time you have
one play you give the ball to Jeffords
and he runs it in I I'd like to see you
score one good cuz you're about to see
it you're about to see it straight to
hell
[Music]
hey man reading the defense graduate
corner okay
listen this is just going to be a
friendly game right we are all on the
same team here
dunder-mifflin team of course if you
beat us you're fired
that's a joke okay let's do it yeah all
right let's stretch it pull stretch Ryan
your stretch let's stretch before I
can't okay okay Ryan you have Darryl I
have Roy really I thought I'd take Roy
no actually
Roy's our best player not lying so
Dwight you have the East German go okay
all right you guys okay we'll be skin
white what should I honor off on just
put it on you sure yes Pam you kind of
have your foot in both camps here why
don't you do the jump ball okay don't
listen to him Pam trust me
tip it my way or sleep in the car
what you gotta be kidding me
hey Peralta boy Sarge hey I'm so psyched
you made it here to the sting that I
definitely told Charles to tell you
about you lied to me I can see that
you're upset but let's just sit down and
talk about it
good talk time to dance fine but I
should warn you I took three years of
tap again Sarge it's so good to see you
just out of curiosity how did you find
out about this I'm a detective sergeant
in the NYPD hold Toby why you cutting me
out of the operation what that's crazy
Boyle come in here and stand in front of
my body and tell them that's crazy go
talk to me now sure if you could be any
vacation oh you let me finish if you
could be any vacation what would you be
I'd be skiing oh no I'm gonna hit you
for real that wasn't for real oh my god
don't worry worried about what about you
getting hurt I don't want your daughters
growing up without a dad I know what
that's like and it sucks and I don't
want it to happen to them why did you
say something to me because I didn't
want to get in your head and have you
freak out again oh I get it
it's been a rough year but I've learned
to embrace my fears it makes me a better
cop tax 1 & 2 are set 30 minutes until
the bogeys arrive
thanks Boyle I love it when you say
bogeys we're gonna have some fun today
party who is ready to play 60
[Applause]
the NFL has a campaign to try to get
kids active for 60 minutes per day and
so we busted a hundred lucky little
buggers from Pawnee and they are going
to get a chance to play with the Colts
okay I guess you would know pleasure to
see you again mr. luck we met briefly
last year at our friend's bachelor party
oh yeah right how are you I normally
don't answer that question but since I
respect your talent I will tell you I am
fine
hi I'm April I stole your wallet guys
are weird
thank you sup girl
keep walking 98 you didn't want to talk
to that guy he plays in the NFL he's a
linebacker skill positions only for
Donna mEagle I got my cold bTW my cold
scarf I got the coats grill going and
the crowning glory cold slippies how you
gonna run a nose run Tommy doesn't run
that's your guys's job now let's go
fetch his football throw fellas I love
sports come on Oscar
what positions do people play wing leg
Jim woody play left photo half tour
definite ok striker huh striker you got
no legs all right all right no no no
it's supposed to be the kickoff kickoff
my strategy is to touch the ball as low
as possible
chalk it up to teamwork okay
I'd dunk Jim yeah watch him why would an
experienced soccer player like yourself
duck at the very last moment okay I'm
just gonna go get some ice does that
make you feel better huh I'm sorry folks
oh yeah Jim sorry Boyle is everything
okay you know with your brain yeah I'm
great having a lot of fun yes I've heard
you say that 162 times you do realize
that if we lose this next match we're
out of the tournament yes but the
important thing has to be had a good
time no the important thing is that we
win the trophy
because I promised Kevin before he left
for Paris that we would do that do you
know why I chose you as my partner
because I'm the most athletic person you
know no because of an article I read in
the Sarah Lawrence Phoenix about a young
man they called squashes unhinged
lunatic
I don't what you're talking about
according to that article that lonely
tick was 27 I know I need him on my team
I need you to unleash the beast
[Music]
let you guys smoke your butts
because ray-ray and the bees don't even
go right we don't give a what
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's it all right let's start with the
basics why don't you just play some
one-on-one see if you can score Andy
guard him he's too big I can't see you
over him it's not fair I think I wants
to be the same size you have to create
space you got to just dribble around
them there you go now what
shoot shoot the ball did I do basketball
kind of try it again Tommy for the dunk
you